throwback no Joker soll jetzt nicht zur
Gewohnheit werden dass ich mich
wöchentlich an den exakt gleichen Ort
setze und über mein Leben Rede
allerdings haben wir jetzt auch eine
Kerze
sogar zwei davon habe ich auch die ist
aber ein bisschen am Leiden ihr fragt
euch allerdings wahrscheinlich gerade
erst mal jo Luca warum jetzt dieses
Video im Titel steht wie geht's weiter
und genau darum geht es tatsächlich auch
denn dafür ist ein Titel auch da ähm ich
möchte einfach ein bisschen darüber
quatschen was mit mir als Person
passiert aktuell und in nächster Zeit
was mit meinen Youtube Kanälen passiert
und auch was mit Peyton und mir passiert
denn ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon auf
Instagram gesehen da habe ich gestern
abend diesen Texte gepostet wir beiden
sind getrennt wir sind nicht mehr
zusammen und ich werde auch nichts
weiter zu sagen ich möchte dass ihr
diese Entscheidung akzeptiert dass ihr
das respektiert vor allem auch unsere
Privatsphäre und das jetzt nicht wilde
Spekulation und Gerüchte um sich
gestreut werden davon kriege ich schon
genug mit nur Payton und ich wissen
beide was passiert ist und ich werde
eventuell demnächst meiner Podcast Folge
ein bisschen drüber quatschen und das
ganze Thema da noch mal so ein bisschen
behandeln aber jetzt aktuell und in
diesem Video nicht bevor jetzt auch über
mein Video von 9 Tagen quatsche was
tatsächlich das kann ich jetzt im
Nachhinein auch noch mal bestätigen das
wichtigste Video meiner Karriere bisher
war möchte ich euch auch noch mal ganz
kurz sagen dass auch auf diesem Video
hier keine Werbung geschaltet ist ich
habe die Vermarktung hier auch wieder
deaktiviert weil ich nicht möchte dass
ihr denkt ey Luca sorgt für
Aufmerksamkeit indem er über seine
mentale Gesundheit redet indem er sich
öffnet und seine psychischen Probleme
preisgibt und steckt sich dadurch noch
Geld in die Tasche durch irgendeine
Werbung die Form Video läuft und ich
fände es auch ein bisschen unpassen wenn
hier vom Video jetzt einfach gesagt
werden würde
jetzt zum Superman erstmal an Euch alle
jedoch die Info kurz noch mal was
passiert ist ich glaube die meisten von
euch haben es mitbekommen ich habe vor 9
Tagen ein Video hier hochgeladen auf
meinem YouTube-Kanal wo ich fast ohne
Notizen ohne roten Faden dann nehme ich
mich habe hergehangelt habe sein Tun
einfach drauflos gequatscht habe indem
ich sehr aufgelöst war emotional auch
teilweise geworden bin und darüber
gequatscht habe dass ich mir Hilfe
suchen werde dass ich und auch Freunde
mir mitgeteilt haben dass ich teils
narzisstische Züge an den Tag lege und
teils ja meine eigene Meinung nicht
hinten anstellen kann dass ich oft und
das hat mir jetzt auch eine Therapeutin
gesagt ich habe mir kurz aufgeschrieben
Impuls durch Brüche habe und eine
Anpassungsstörung bei mir vorliegt
das habe ich in dem Video gesagt von 9
Tagen und daraufhin ist dieses Video
extrem durch Decke gegangen und
das wollte ich nicht das hört sich jetzt
vielleicht dumm an jetzt im Nachhinein
denke ich mir das war vielleicht gut
dass das Video so viele Aufrufe
gesammelt hat das haben sich jetzt
mittlerweile irgendwie eineinhalb
Millionen Leute angeguckt das ist 30 mal
das Stadion hier vom ersten Fußballclub
Köln und ich weiß nur dass ich dieses
Video hier von meiner Kamera aufgenommen
habe und wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte
hey du trittst dir vor 30 mal diesen
Stadion übereinander auf hätte ich
wahrscheinlich mein Mund nicht mehr
aufgekriegt deswegen war es für mich auf
jeden Fall der richtige und wichtige und
beste Schritt darüber zu reden mich zu
öffnen weil einerseits mir extrem viele
Leute die dadurch geschrieben haben dass
sie sich ähnlich fühlen nicht sich in
mir Wiedersehen aber auch mentale
Probleme haben dass ihre psychische
Gesundheit auch nicht komplett perfekt
ist so wie es bei keinem Menschen der
Fall ist und auf der anderen Seite habe
ich allerdings auch durch dieses Video
mich selber gezwungen an mir zu arbeiten
weil ich weiß dass solche Sachen dass
solche Probleme nicht von heute auf
morgen kommen sondern sich über die Zeit
anbahnen und über die Zeit entstehen
und dieses Video mir einfach auch extrem
viel hilft diese Sache jetzt wirklich
final anzugehen ich hatte in Hamburg
auch einen Therapeut mit dem ich
allerdings nie so ganz warm geworden und
mit dem konnte ich mich auch nie so Dieb
über diese Sachen unterhalten weil sich
irgendwie nicht richtig angefühlt hat
allerdings bin ich jetzt in Behandlung
bei anderen Leuten und bin absolut happy
und ich sehe die ersten Mini Erfolge und
durch dieses Video und dadurch dass die
ganze öffentlich jetzt die
Öffentlichkeit jetzt auch dieses Video
sich angeguckt hat und da drauf guckt
egal ob es eins live im Radio war oder
ob es zahlreiche Zeitungsartikel waren
oder in den Medien oder im Fernsehen
oder Leute die mir daraufhin auch
geschrieben haben davon mitbekommen
haben übel viele Fußballer einfach aus
der ersten Fußballbundesliga haben mir
geschrieben wir haben andere influencer
influencerin geschrieben das haben wir
auch extrem viele Youtuber Stream auf
das Video reagiert wir haben Leute
geschrieben und sich geöffnet die ich
teilweise nicht mal kannte
das ist irre und
ich weiß einfach dass jetzt so viele
Augen auf mich gucken und auf meine
Entwicklung gucken dass ich weiß ich
will das nicht verkacken das hört sich
so ein bisschen gezwungen jetzt an aber
ich will an mir arbeiten ich will ein
besserer Mensch werden ich will das
beste werden was ich aus mir rausholen
kann und das war der Grund für dieses
Video meine Intention und was ich
allerdings auch sagen wollte war dass es
wirklich sehr sehr sehr viel war was in
diesem Video hoch gekommen ist ich war
sehr emotional ich habe an zwei drei
Stellen auch einen Trainer vergossen
musste dann kurz kacken weil ich einfach
drauflos gequatscht habe weil ich
einfach meinen Gefühlen frei und
aufgelassen habe weil ich dachte das
wäre der richtige weg und ich habe mich
einfach danach gefühlt ich bin immer ein
Mensch der eigentlich sein Handy hat
Notizen und gefühlt in Klemmbrett mit
irgendwelchen Punkten die abgearbeitet
werden müssen das kennt ihr von mir aus
dem Podcast seit drei Jahren allerdings
hat sich das sehr sehr gut angefühlt
einfach mal so zu quatschen und sich zu
öffnen und
dadurch haben glaube ich viele meine
Situation so ein bisschen überschätzt
ich bin nicht depressiv das ist ein ganz
ganz großes Wort was ich eigentlich gar
nicht in den Mund nehmen möchte ich bin
froh am Leben zu sein ich habe keine
bösen schlimmen Gedanken gerade aktuell
ich
finde es auch total crazy mich haben
Leute teilweise im Urlaub angesprochen
ich war die Tage mit meiner Mom zum
allerersten Mal für vier Tage allein im
Urlaub wir waren im Saarland wir sind
sehr sehr viel spazieren gegangen haben
unser Handy weggelegt und haben
gequatscht auch eine Menge und da haben
mich Leute an der Rezeption angesprochen
vom Hotel dann meinten ey wir haben ein
Video gesehen alles Gute Digger ich
wurde im Streichelzoo von Jungs
angesprochen die 14 Jahre alt waren die
meinten ey Bro wir haben ein Video
gesehen in der Schule im Unterricht
alles Gute Bruder du packst das Gute
Besserung mich haben Leute im Restaurant
50-Jährige gesehen haben mich in der
Zeitung gelesen irgendwie davon sind zu
mir ein Tisch gekommen und gesagt ich
möchte dich einfach mal drücken und habe
mich einfach so ein Arm genommen
und die können jetzt auch schon wieder
heulen gerade aber das sind so
Situationen wo ich mir einfach so dachte
das habe ich nicht verdient ich
sehe mich selber aktuell schon als
besseren Menschen als noch vor neun
Tagen beim mir das auch gesagt wurde man
darf sich jetzt nicht runter machen
lassen erst recht nicht durch sich
selbst
[Musik]
aber es war schon irre und es hat sich
nicht so angefühlt als hätte ich das
verdient gehabt weil
ich wirklich an vielen Stellen keinen
perfekter Mensch bin und ich weiß dass
kein Mensch perfekt ist das haben wir
auch ganz viele von euch geschrieben wir
haben auch ganz ganz viele geschrieben
du bist kein Narzisst das ist so ein
riesiges Wort das bist du nicht
aber
ja ich weiß einfach dass ich aktuell
nicht die Personen die ich sein möchte
und da arbeite ich an mir und ich merke
die ersten Mini Erfolge ich habe auch
hier einige Sachen die ich machen kann
wenn ich wieder an solche Situationen
kommen sollte wie man das bewältigt und
ich merke dass ich schon wieder
emotional werde von daher ich möchte
dieses Video auch gar nicht länger
halten als es ist ich möchte einfach nur
ein riesig großes Danke aussprechen an
euch
es war für mich einfach in der letzten
Zeit sehr häufig so als wenn ich in
meinem Auto gesessen hätte auf der
Autobahn und ich müsste eigentlich
rechts abfahren die Ausfahrt nehmen
allerdings ging das nicht die Lenkung
war blockiert
und dann sagt das Navi okay du hast die
Ausfahrt verpasst nimm die nächste
Ausfahrt
und ich wollte einlenken und es ging
wieder nicht und der Umweg den ich
fahren musste wurde immer länger
und ich
fühle mich zum ersten Mal jetzt so als
wenn ich wirklich diese Kurve gerade
kriegen würde
als würde ich die Ausfahrt sehen und
wird jetzt merken ah die Lenkung sind
total dummes Beispiel das dass ich
Beispiele nicht so gut kann aber nicht
so merken würde wow die Lenkung
funktioniert wieder und
es ist Licht am Ende des Tunnels mal
alle einmal Sprichwörter hier raushauen
und ich will euch auch nicht länger
therapieren ich wollte einfach nur ganz
ganz groß danke sagen Danke für eure
extrem lieben Kommentare danke für die
so extrem riesige Resonanz auf mein
Video ich habe dieses Video in erster
Linie gemacht um euch darüber zu
informieren dass einfach weniger Videos
kommen und dass ich an mir arbeite
aber das ist jetzt
das ist ja gerade übel am Donner dicker
wie hat das Deutschland geschafft
innerhalb von einer Woche von 30 Grad zu
10 Grad Zug absoluter Regenzeit zu
kommen ist aber auch egal ich möchte
wirklich wie bereits gesagt einfach nur
groß danke sagen ich verstehe nicht
warum man das macht ich weiß es sieht
schöner aus Sonnen Herz aber ich finde
das einfach viel chilliger und er danke
schön von meinem tiefsten Herzen an Euch
alle die mir geschrieben haben die haben
mich gedacht haben die ganzen Leute die
hinter mir stehen ich werde euch nicht
enttäuschen
es wird auch mit Youtube Videos
weitergehen übrigens es kommt die Tage
ziemlich geiles Video coole Sache die
wir machen können es kommt auch die Tage
aidablock da habe ich auch so ein
bisschen was gefilmt lukschuh geht es ja
eh die ganze Zeit schon mehr oder
weniger weiter also ich werde auch
weiter wieder Content machen weil das
eben auch das ist was ich feier was ich
gut finde womit ich mich auch ablenken
kann und was meine Leidenschaft ist und
immer noch mein Hobby auch wenn ich
damit mittlerweile Geld verdiene
genau ich habe euch lieb wir sehen uns
die Tage macht's gut